podcast go watch the full interview with
savvy third it's out right now
it's uh it it's going crazy too uh shout
out to lrg man he said he wanted to
freestyle he's about to say everybody
coming up here let's get let's get one
in so yeah i'm just trying to be clear
let's be clear right now i love the beat
selection fire that [ __ ] come on
get it done baby
first one yeah
my first one
yeah
number three
[Music]
ain't no target we do it i got nothing
to prove hey [ __ ] are choosing pull
off the lightning exclusive a night it's
a movie yeah but we booming wasn't used
to this life but now we ballin on the
shoes
[Music]
yeah
let me be clear
hold on
it's kind of late for [ __ ] effort i'm
selling all the way around that's my
greatest treasure yeah he's a snapper
don't nobody set the bar better play
along like a fool but i'll walk clever
i'm in the drive picking hotties up
right before this i just caught up and
shot him
i don't know what these [ __ ] thought
it was [ __ ] got it but i'm tripping
like it's not enough they not waiting on
your mixtape i just nailed it to the
cross can't sit straight these [ __ ]
really think we can't tell they [ __ ]
fake i'm paid to be the savior of the
crips sake you're probably hot don't
you're black but you're not this if he a
beast i'm a [ __ ] like ness
strength of victory i'm sorry and i'm
still involved i'm failing for the cause
[ __ ]
know that everything you see and
everything you see understand your
gamble you gonna take the teeter-league
purple label jeans killing me if they
came for me remember days i pleaded for
the [ __ ] to wait for me temporary
scheme tried to hurt me fatally trying
to catch my dream team so far away to me
always wondering did you grow out of
hate for me it happened over time no
it's not the same to me
it make time for skis this is dreams i'm
achieving me reaching my pieces
all my actions got meanings actually got
cracking no ass for my reason black on
my back let it [ __ ] to the core
i had [ __ ] galore you know it's
regularly this [ __ ] on the floor classic
i give them what they waiting for
classic got given what they waiting for
yeah that's how we're doing things man
yeah that's how we're gonna let that
sink in
all right these parties that's cartier
these vba
i'm out of here
hey you guys just watched uh freestyle
uh presented by lrg shout out to lrg
they just did this phoenix suns collab
that is fire um and they got some of the
freshest gear in the world and right now
if you head over to lrg's website we're
gonna put it on the screen
and you use the promo code bootleg
you'll get 30 off at checkout that's 30
off as much clothes as you could put in
your [ __ ] cart
at lrg's website l
r g com use the promo code bootleg save
30
off we got another freestyle coming next
week presented to you by lrg